[Music]
what's up guys
jared here with another vlog season 4
rick and morty starts this weekend and
accordingly
we're relaunching our rick and morty
podcast the squanch
so to celebrate i thought i'd take a
little time to do something very
very stupid i'm going to dissect the
infamous rick and morty copy pasta
if you're unaware of what i'm referring
to a rick and morty copy pasta went
viral in mid-2017 and is
likely plastered all over the comments
section of this video
for the less internet obsessed view a
copy pasta is a copied block of text
that is pasted
in response to a post usually as a means
of trolling the writer of said post
the rick and morty one often used to
sarcastically rebut
criticisms of the show or make fun of
its die-hard fans
goes like this to be fair you have to
have a
very high iq to understand rick and
morty the humor is extremely subtle
and without a solid grasp of theoretical
physics most of the jokes will go
over a typical viewer's head there's
also rick's nihilistic outlook which is
deftly woven into his characterization
his personal philosophy draws heavily
from narada naya voya literature for
instance
the fans understand this stuff they have
the intellectual capacity to truly
appreciate the depths of these jokes
to realize that they're not just funny
they say something deep
about life as a consequence people who
dislike rick and morty truly
are idiots of course they wouldn't
appreciate for instance
the humor in rick's existential
catchphrase wubba lubba dub dub
which itself is a cryptic reference to
turgenie's russian epic
fathers and sons i'm smirking right now
just imagining one of those edel-pated
simpletons scratching their heads in
confusion as dan harmon's
genius wit unfolds itself on their
television screens
what fools how i pity them and yes by
the way i do have a rick and morty
tattoo and no
you cannot see it it's for the ladies
eyes only and even then they have to
demonstrate that they're within 5
iq points of my own preferably lower
beforehand
nothing personnel kid even if this copy
pasta was written as a joke we've all
probably met this person
how could you you ignorant plebe ever
understand
true art like i do a person who's read
upwards of 30 wikipedia articles
regardless it's hilarious but me being
me
i really clung to the literary
references i'm going to sound like a
douche here but i've read fathers and
sons which is supposedly the inspiration
for
i haven't read it in years but i
remember enough to know that this claim
is obvious bold
and that chances are the writer was
pulling some random russian novel out of
their ass to make fun of certain people
on the internet
who cite obscure works of philosophy and
literature when talking about cartoons
bravo internet
but then recently i was awakened by a
sinking
thought a thought i would try
desperately to push back into my
subconscious
what if this copy pasta is actually not
entirely bold so humor me as i dig my
own grave in this vlog
on overthinking the rick and morty copy
pasta now the copy pasta is funny for a
few reasons
one because this guy is making egregious
interpretive leaps in order to elevate
his favorite cartoon
two because he's just so damn smug and
three
we can't help but love a little roast of
people who like us
love literature and philosophy but
allegedly unlike us
are total dicks about it the origins of
the pasta are disputed
according to knowyourmeme.com the
earliest known variation was posted by a
redditor named nikish on
r cringeanarchy some believe the writer
was entirely in earnest in their
proclamation that the show
can only be understood by geniuses
others think
they were being ironic after thinking
about it for a while i've come to the
conclusion that whoever wrote it
was serious let's dive in the original
writer of the pasta makes three big
claims
one that you have to have working
knowledge of theoretical physics to
understand the jokes in rick and morty
ah i thought it was further away this is
clearly false
although some of the jokes pay lip
service to scientific ideas the show is
not
overly concerned with scientific
fidelity nor should it be
we covered a bit of this in the last
part of our philosophy of rick and morty
video so if you want the specifics
check that out two that rick's nihilism
draws heavily
from naradanaya volia literature narada
nayavolia for those of you who don't
truly get rick and morty was a radical
organization in russia during the 19th
century that
assassinated a bunch of tsarist
officials eventually culminating in the
killing of tsar alexander ii
narada naya volya literature i'm
assuming refers to the non-fiction texts
that
influenced the movement such as the
works of figures like sergey nichev
mikhail bakunin or pyotr lavrov but i
couldn't find
naradaya volya literature specifically
in my research
unless they mean pamphlets or something
but i digress
many involved in this movement or the
similar one that preceded it called the
neurotnics
believed that anything in service of
revolution was justified
and thus were labeled nihilists in this
specific russian context nihilism meant
agitating for revolution against the
tsarist order
a sentiment popular among the younger
generation writer maya steppenberg
quoting historian nicholas ryozanovsky
claimed that nihilism meant above all
else a fundamental rebellion against
accepted values and standards
against abstract thought and family
control against the lyric poetry and
school discipline
against religion and rhetoric nihilism
as we refer to it today
is similar but maybe more universal it's
a rejection of any standard
of value meaning or morality as we've
covered in a handful of videos
rick and morty is saturated with this
sentiment primarily through rick
nothing you do matters your existence is
a lie nobody gets it nothing you think
matters matters this isn't special this
this is happening infinite times across
infinite realities
including this yes now i'm going to be
very generous to the writer of the copy
pasta and say that he or she was
probably thinking that since the overtly
nihilistic rick is an anti-federation
revolutionary who eventually brings the
entire thing crumbling to the ground
the war in which we fought is far from
over we live our lives in hiding the
galactic government considers us
terrorists
he bears similarities to the attitude of
narada naya volya
but there's little to no connective
tissue to prove that rick's personal
philosophy
is specifically drawn from this
organization there's nothing about being
a nihilistic political rebel that is
unique to this particular movement
so the connection is perhaps paper-thin
but
not nonsensical which brings us to the
writer's third point
that wubba lubba dub dub is a cryptic
reference to ivan ter genyev's novel
fathers and sons i was almost certain
that this citation was pulled at random
in an effort to sound smart
but again there is some logic to the
author's thinking
i hate to admit it but i scoured this
book trying to find
any justification for the claim that
wubble of a dub dub has some bearing in
the text
and of course in as much as i am able to
tell it's
bull but it'd be remiss of me not to
mention that there
are some key similarities between
fathers and sons
and rick and morty according to
steppenberg the nihilist movement in
russia was reacting to two main things
one turmoil following the emancipation
of the serfs
and two the publication of two books
that spoke to the younger generation's
disillusionment
they were what is to be done by nikolai
schernachevsky
and fathers and sons by yvonne tergenyev
now importantly dergenyev was not part
of narada nayavolia
nor was fathers and sons explicitly
associated with them
however the book did speak to the
growing nihilism of the russian youth
it was hugely controversial at the time
of its release
readers couldn't quite figure out if
turgeniev was promoting nihilism
or denigrating it fathers and sons
focuses on the kirsanav family as their
son al-qaedi brings his radical friend
yevgeny bazarov to his family's estate
after graduating from university a
nihilist
bazarov challenges and calls for the
destruction of
all the old russian ideas that don't
have any basis in reason or science
as he famously says what's important is
twice to his four
and all the rest's nonsense his demeanor
deeply disturbs archie's family but
bazarov dies before he's able to realize
any of these ideas
the book is essentially about the gulf
between the value systems of
fathers and sons during this time period
if i were again
being extremely generous to the writer
of the copy pasta i'd say
yeah there's a similarity in the way
rick constantly trivializes anything not
bound in science
what people call love is just a chemical
reaction that compels animals to breed
it hits hard morty then it slowly fades
leaving you stranded in a failing
marriage i did it your parents are gonna
do it
break the cycle morty rise above focus
on science
to the nihilistic bazarov some of his
diatribes speak to the same sense of
cosmic insignificance rick and morty
often reflects on
the tiny little place i occupy is so
small in relation to the rest of space
where i am not
and where it's none of my business and
the amount of time which i'll succeed in
living is so insignificant by comparison
with the eternity where i haven't been
and never will be and yet in this atom
in this mathematical point the blood
circulates the brain works
and even desires something as well
what's your ugliness
what sheer nonsense but again
there's no reason to make this
connection there are plenty of
characters in literature that struggle
with such ideas
and citing this book seems like
cherry-picking
so does rick and morty draw from
naradanayavulia and include specific
references to essential texts during the
nihilist movement in 19th century russia
no definitely not but does rick and
morty as a cultural artifact
as one of the most successful animated
shows on cable
have a similar function in the zeitgeist
that turgeniev's fathers and sons did
of introducing the masses to nihilistic
ideas
of presenting a flawed central character
that leaves the audience not knowing if
they should identify with his worldview
or condemn it i'm inclined to say
probably
so there you have it you can now
pedantically discuss the dumbest thing
on the internet
you're welcome anyway thanks for
watching and be sure to subscribe to our
rick and morty podcast the squanch it's
on google play apple podcasts and our
channel wisecast
we'll be breaking down every episode of
this very short season
and as always thanks for watching guys
peace